qui se souvient de la meuf avec des
ongles hyper long là elle y en a qui ont
déjà vu cette image ou pas si oui cette
vidéo est faite pour vous sinon rester
car elle est aussi fait pour vous qui se
souvient ça c'était encore plus gros le
buzz de l
la dame capable de sortir très fort ses
yeux de ses orbites saab et romain peu
projet mais ça c'est viola je vous parle
de trucs c'est assez vieux eh bien
écoutez la chose que ces deux personnes
ont en commun c'est un record du monde
le record du monde des onglets plus long
et le record du monde des yeux qui
sortent le plus de leurs orbites
d'ailleurs petite anecdote triste sur
cette dame aux ongles longs elle a perdu
ses ongles comment elle commence cette
idée elle a perdu ses ongles dans un
accident de voiture
et croyez-moi elle aurait préféré se
casser une jambe même dans tous ses
ongles se sont péter ça faisait 30 ans
qu'ils étaient en train de pousser et du
coup elle est dégoûté parce que elle a
dit qu'elle mourra avant de ré atteindre
la longueur qu'ils avaient et ces voix
là si l'anecdote autruches traite russe
est la vraie question dans cette
histoire c'est comment il faisait pour
conduire avec des ongles comme ça tu ne
peux pas tenir un volant à l'époque je
me souviens on m'avait acheté un livre
qui s'appelait le guinness world briques
rouges
je crois qu'à une édition chaque année
où il ya des nouveaux records du monde
et c'est trop marrant mais vraiment
alors aujourd'hui ils ont même une
chaîne youtube 1 où ils montent du coût
des vidéos des records du monde et en
fait c'est ouf comme via un truc très
officiel s'il ya des records pour tout
imaginer un record là ça existe c'est
sûr il ya eu un [ __ ] de huissier qui
est venu valider le record est qu'à
contrôler si tout était bien en règle
c'est très sérieux
aujourd'hui je vais voir un peu comment
ces records du monde aux ont évolué et
je suis sûr qu'ils les trucs encore plus
insolite que la dame aux ongs et la dame
aux yeux qui étaient les deux trucs les
plus fous à l'époque ça avait fait un
buzz mais incroyable mais aujourd'hui je
suis sûr qu'à dix fois plus drôle est
improbable c'est évident allez c'est
parti
ah mais c'est tellement précis attend
georges turner l'homme qui a résolu le
plus rapidement un rubik's cube sur un
pogo sur un pogo c'est une discipline il
a le record chercheurs c'est un gars ils
n'arrivaient pas à battre le record du
monde pour résoudre un rubik's cube donc
il s'est dit bah je vais battre le
record du monde pour résoudre un rubik's
cube sur un pogo il ya beaucoup cette
mentalité en fait de hockey bon celui là
ok à des gens qu'ils ont mais le 100 m
sur des échasses personnes là ce record
là je vais faire un record du monde moi
bref je veux voir ça c'est parti très
spéciaux guinness world records
[Musique]
cet objet au pourquoi il a été créé par
deux aces au pinceau lite on perd celui
qui t'a tout transmis ok c'est même lui
qui t'a offert le pogo stick gâteau
d'anniversaire parle mieux ton père
gamins adorent j'espère il a expliqué
comment l'idée de faire un rubik's cube
sur un pogo stick ce qui est totalement
incompatible lui est venue
[Musique]
mais en vrai c'est balèze de son
quinquennat et le record du monde est
détenu par le seul mec qui fait du
rubik's cube sur un pogo stick à part
toi le seul tu as un concurrent et les
meilleurs pour le moment je suis méchant
pardon mais je trouve ça fou la plus
grande caravane en lego
fois ils ont tout fait en lego c-288
1630 lego a well elle fonctionne quoi tu
peux vraiment accroché attaquer c'est
partir en camping avec elle les
fonctionnels ok je m'y attendais pas wow
c'est triste un mais j'ai envie de voir
un accident de la route avec cette
caravane quoi si horrible mais j'ai
envie de voir ce qui se passe
[ __ ] les mecs qu'ils y ont passé du
temps en fait ce que j'adore là c'est
que ça pue la passion quoi bien joué
franchement bravo le plus de cartes
lancer dans une pastèque en une minute
je voulais dire souvenez vous imaginez
encore là ça existe c'est vrai assez en
chine
déjà cette idée de moi je veux juste que
les gars et raconte la première fois
qu'ils ont fait ça comment ils ont eu
l'idée on a tous mangé de la pastèque
ici qui parmi nous c'est dit elle ça
peut être stylée d'envoyer une carte sur
la pastèque et genre elles se croisent
dedans on est quelques-uns je pense
[Musique]
mais ouais ouais
mais un froid mais lafuma là pour
tourner à la base ça pue pas l'affairé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne sait pas considéré comme une arme
blanche les cartes mec excuse moi mais
lui t'embrouille dans la rue il sera
paquet de cartes il te des coupes mais
qu en fait j'ai envie d'essayer
je vous jure l'aube cette fois que c'est
une pastèque j'essaye 100% vous aussi
faites pas genre on va tous essayer sa
mère quoi largesses hoeven leiter quoi
ah c'est le plus grand ok c'est un mec à
fabriquer le plus grand allume-feu du
monde et ses membres au québec
[Musique]
j'ai du mal à comprendre la vie de ces
gars là mais le doji le danger de ce
qu'on est en train de voir
on dirait des enfants hyper doué à qui
on a offert les moyens de faire des
bêtises
encore plus grosse attente
excusez moi mais c'est pas parce que tu
mets un lance flammes dans un skin
d'allumer feu que c'est dans la
catégorie à lui fait il ya un problème
là les juges or je commence à douter du
sérieux de vous record du monde la
regarde
à noter donc sinon ça prend quand même
exactement le mécanisme d'un petit quoi
ils ont juste tout fait un méga grand
hockey ça me va c'est validé par lucas
et sa communauté moi et ma taille de
boucher dans et au c'est dur ce qui est
cool c'est que ça se voit pas du tout en
fait c'est pas une déformation qu'il a
ça se voit pas du tout c'est ses
couleurs c'est un talent ce secret
[Musique]
quand tu as l'air de souffrir quand tu
le fais frérot terme de souffrir
n'empêche quand il va chez le dentiste
il a peut-être pas besoin d'arv c'est le
truc qui te maintient la bouche ouverte
là qui ça fait trop mal ça il n'avait
pas besoin de ça j'y voit du positif
dans ce record bien joué à lui le mec
parle le plus vite
aa c'est lui il y en a à nouveau tous
les hommes armés qui parle le plus vite
au monde tient pas rigueur à comprendre
préparez-vous ce qu'ils comprennent vous
êtes bilingue voilà c'est le test qui
est bilingue là sur les vidéos sont
parties à cesser mes vidéos en 2014 j'ai
besoin que tu ne peux le faire je sais
pas c'est quoi les critères en fait où
tu le fais bien ou alors tu fais mal
faut que chaque mot soit parfaitement
audible c'est ça si je peux le faire
excuse moi mais c'est dur en fait alors
attends ne dis pas que c'est ce que je
pense pitié le plus de slips en 30
secondes
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure je voulais
dire imaginez encore là ça existe à mes
genoux allaient mettre lui même les doit
être debout
ok y'a quand même des critères âge j'ai
envie d'essayer il doit les mettre lui
même seul en étant debout
[Musique]
ok c'est un italien et il en a mis 13
bob est ce que c'est une vraie question
les slips par exemple là en l'occurrence
succès des slips et ce qu'il faut que
son agent homologué qui correspondent à
certains critères ou est-ce que tu peut
tricher et genre en vrai tu mets du s
est tu prends des slips xxl et du coup
le trou pour passer dès janvier plus il
est plus large toit est ce que c'est
possible de trouver des petites douille
comme ça pour choper le croit encore du
monde ou est ce que c'est vraiment très
sérieux genre chez pat un record du
monde mais était ce clip était pas
homologué ce taux a prêché le pam lancer
la pierre à chaque fois jamais fumé le
record du mec qui a monté le plus de
marche en étant sur la tête fois la
première fois encore une fois on y
revient mais la première fois comment il
a eu l'idée
bon déjà cet équilibre est important
[Musique]
franks et escaliers même à pied j'ai la
flemme de le monter ils le montrent sur
la tête c'est bon j'ai envie genre de
leur dire les gars prenait du recul là
rendez-vous cours de la situation on en
est là on n'arrive plus à se départir
faut que les gens m'ont des escaliers
sur la tête pour qu'on éprouve quelque
chose c'est tellement dangereux en vrai
gros respect à ce gars c'est tellement
dangereux puis plus immondes plus et
d'orge pour ol a failli tomber mais là
je suis pris au jeu critique mairesse a
fait deux minutes 53 que je regarde je
suis à fond
c'est la dernière mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin je veux trop que ce gars soit mon
voisin et le croiser dans la cage
d'escalier un jour où l'ascenseur est en
panne
à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est mon rêve à
le mecque à décapsuler le plus de
bouteille avec sa tête nonda des
décapsuleurs tranquille ou des briques
et dans le pire des cas lui il a sa tête
c'est bon pour vous ce public qui ne
prend aucun plaisir mec je pense à ma
grand-mère là faut que je me faut que je
m'en serve à grand mère c'est qu'a vécu
des choses beaucoup de choses qui a vu
de ces le temps passé l'arrivée
technologie des trucs
j'aimerais qu'elle s'en rende compte que
tout çà çà çà vais arriver à ce point
merde eh bien écoutez de lapins de
d'avoir eu les oreilles bouchées pendant
une heure je n'ai pas réalisé au début
qu'à écouter j'espère que ça vous a plu
c'est exactement ce que je pensais c'est
tout ce que je pensais qu'il ya de plus
en plus de records bizarre insolite à la
fois pour notre plus grand plaisir est à
la fois c'est un peu déprimant faut pas
oublier que les records du monde la
rouvraie ils sont juste donné par le
guinness world records de bouc et en
fait c'est vraiment pas un institut
officiel de l'état chez pas quoi hein
c'est vraiment juste une marque de bière
à base d'où le fait qu'ils aient des
records hyper insolites et qui n'est pas
vraiment de sens afin que soient pas du
tout des disciplines officielles c'est
bien d'avoir un record du monde mais
quand il ya que deux gars dans ta
discipline ça a moins de valeur que
quand d'antenne sip ligne à des millions
de gens jusque précision au cas où il ya
plein de trucs qui sont très dangereux
affaires n'essayez pas les reproduire
chez vous façon il y aura pas de 18,6 et
chez vous donc y aura personne pour
valider le record donc ne tentez pas
tenter un record sur un jeu vidéo là là
pas problème mais je veux pas être
responsable de chevilles cassées ou deux
gars qui sont plantés tensions records
du gars qui surprend des gens qui sont
dans le couloir
j'ai pas le record du monde à bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo c'est chaud
[Musique]